>> Laura: PANEL, STAY RIGHT
THERE AND WE WILL SEE LATER IN
THE SHOW.
THERE IS SO MUCH BREAKING NEWS
TONIGHT BUT FIRST I WANT TO
BRING IN PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
PERSONAL ATTORNEY RUDY GIULIANI.
RUDY, FIRST, ARE YOU IN TOUCH
WITH THE PRESIDENT?
HAVE YOU SPOKEN TO HIM THE LAST
COUPLE OF HOURS OR TONIGHT, AND
WHAT IS HE THINKING?
>> OF COURSE, HE HAS MY CLIENT
AND I CAN'T TELL YOU WHAT I TALK
TO HIM ABOUT PARTICULARLY AT A
TIME LIKE THIS.
IT IS A ATTORNEY/CLIENT
PRIVILEGE AND I KNOW THE
DEMOCRATS DO NOT RESPECT THAT
WERE ANY CONSTITUTIONAL
PRESIDENT -- PRIVILEGE THE
PRESIDENT HAS.
BUT I THINK YOU ARE RIGHT THEY
STEPPED INTO WHAT THEY REALIZE
AND IT REMINDS ME OF A FIGHT
SWINGING WILDLY AGAINST A
SKILLED FIGHTER WHO HAS A
GREAT RIGHT HAND AND PUTS HIM
RIGHT DOWN.
THEY HAVE LOOKED INTO SOMETHING
AND I WAS HOPING FOR SIX MONTHS
BUT WHAT THEY'D EXPOSED IS
PROBABLY WHAT IT WILL TURN OUT
TO BE COMPONENT OF THE MAJOR
SCANDALS IN THE EARLY PART OF
THE 20TH CENTURY WHICH IS
JOE BIDEN.
IT IS A LOT OF MONEY, LAURA, NOT
JUST YOU CAN'T KNOW MIKE
UKRAINE.
IT IS A VERY CENTER -- SERIES
PATTERN CONTRACT BUT THE SENATE
WITH HIS BROTHER, ENRICHING
HIMSELF ON BIDEN'S PUBLIC
OFFICE.
THE NUMBERS GOT OUTRAGEOUS
DURING THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION.
FIVE, $6 MILLION TO A SON WHO IS
SERIOUSLY INCOMPETENT PERSON.
WE'VE GOT TO PUT ON THE PORT OF
THE MOST CORRUPT COMPANY IN THE
UKRAINE.
I HAD THE RECORDS OF A
$3 MILLION PAYMENT TO
MR. BIDEN'S SON.
I HAVE THE RECORDS, THE DATES.
IT WENT FROM UKRAINE.
>> Laura:
AS Laura:
ASKEaura:
ASKEDura:
ASKED Ta:
ASKED THE TWO LAWYERS, EVIDENCE
OF GUILTY KNOWLEDGE.
>> Laura: RUDY, RUDY, I WANT
TO MOVE THE CONVERSATION FORWARD
BECAUSE WE'VE HIT THIS AND HAD
YOU ON MONTHS TALKING ABOUT
THIS.
>> NOBODY PAYS ATTENTION TO IT
UNTIL NOW.
>> Laura: NO, WE PAID
ATTENTION TO IT IN MAY OR APRIL.
>> THE KRUPP MEDIA PAID
ATTENTION TO IT.
>> Laura: EVERYBODY HAS THEIR
OWN AGENDA.
>> THE DEMOCRATS COME I THINK
WHAT THEY ARE DOING IS COVERING
UP FOR WHAT WILL TURN OUT TO BE
MASSIVE CORRUPTION IN THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION.
HE GOT $1.5 BILLION FROM CHINA.
>> Laura: THE PHONE TRANSCRIPT
THAT'S GOING TO BE RELEASED,
OFFICIALLY TELLING FOLKS FROM
THE WHITE HOUSE TONIGHT THAT
THERE ARE A FEW WORDS IN THE
TRANSCRIPT THAT WILL RAISE
EYEBROWS BUT NOWHERE AS
INFLAMMATORY AS THE DEMOCRATS
HAVE SUGGESTED.
>> IS NO WHERE NEAR WHAT BIDEN
OR CHRIS WHO SHOULD BE
IMPEACHED.
HE WENT TO SEE THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UKRAINE AND TOLD THE
PRESIDENT OF UKRAINE IF YOU HE
COOPERATES WITH THE PRESIDENT,
THEY WILL CUT OFF AID.
THAT IS A QUID PRO QUO.
THAT IS THREATENING.
NANCY PELOSI WE WOULD BE
OUTRAGED.
THEY SHOULD HAVE IMPEACHED HIM.
>> Laura: A VERY INTERESTING
BREW OF QUID PRO QUO.
>> I DON'T EVEN THINK SHE
ANNOUNCED QUID PRO QUO AND I
DON'T KNOW WHAT THE CRIME IS.
THE REALITY IS, JOE BIDEN
ACTUALLY MADE A VERY WELL
COMMITTED SOMETHING CALLED
CRANES, $1.5 BILLION FROM CHINAT
CRANES, $1.5 BILLION FROM CHINAO
YEARS AGO NEGOTIATING WITH
CHINA AND YOU ARE FEELING.
>> Laura: THAT WILL NEVER
HAPPEN.
>> WHAT DO YOU MEAN IT WILL
NEVER HAPPEN?
>> Laura: IT WAS AN APPARENT,
IT WAS AN APPARENT --
>> CHINA DID NOT INVEST IN THEIR
OWN CHALLENGED SON WITH
$1.5 BILLION.
THEY BOUGHT THE VICE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES AND EVEN IF
YOU ARE A DEMOCRAT, YOU SHOULD
BE SHOCKED BY THAT.
THIS POLITICAL PARTY IS SO
CORRUPT, IT STINKS.
WHEN THE BIDEN CORRUPTION COMES
OUT, AND WE LOOK HOW MUCH MONEY
CLINT MADE UP THE SECRETARY OF
STATE'S OFFICE.
LOOK HOW MUCH MONEY CARRIES
STEPSON MADE IN THE SAME
TRANSACTION.
AND WHO WASN'T MAKING MONEY AND
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION.
>> Laura: HOLD ON BECAUSE
"THE WASHINGTON POST" IS COME
OUT TONIGHT AND YOU ARE THE
FOCUS NOT A SHOCKER.
THE WHISTLE REPORT ON THE TRUMP
CALL, IT INCLUDES REFERENCES TO
OTHER DEVELOPMENTS TIED TO THE
PRESIDENT INCLUDING EFFORTS BY
GIULIANI TO AND SEARCH HIMSELF
INTO A UKRAINIAN RELATIONS, RUDY
DID ALL OF THIS.
ONE U.S. OFFICIAL SAID.
AND THIS SHOWS WE ARE HIM
INJECTING HIMSELF INTO THE
PROCESS.
INSIDERS SAYING YOU MUCKED THIS
UP, YOUR RESPONSE.
>> MAN, YOU KNOW WHO I DID AT
THE REQUEST OF?
THE STATE DEPARTMENT.
I NEVER TALK TO UKRAINIAN
OFFICIAL UNTIL THE STATE
DEPARTMENT CALLED ME AND ASKED
ME TO DO IT.
AND THEN I REPORTED TO EVERY
CONVERSATION BACK TO THEM.
LAURA, I'M A PRETTY GOOD LAWYER,
JUST A COUNTRY LAWYER, BUT IT'S
ALL RIGHT HERE, RIGHT HERE.
THE FIRST CALL FROM THE
STATE DEPARTMENT.
THE DEBRIEFING OF THE STATE.
>> Laura: WHY ARE THEY OUT TO
GET YOU?
WHY ARE THEY OUT TO GET YOU?
>> I WILL COMPLEMENT MY STUFF
BECAUSE I DO A GOOD JOB AND THEY
TRY TO DESTROY EVERYONE.
THEY WILL NOT INTIMIDATE ME.
IN FACT, I'M GOING TO WORK
HARDER BECAUSE I DON'T GET
INTIMIDATED BY BULLIES.
I HAVE A CHAPTER IN MY BOOK
ABOUT STANDING UP TO BULLIES.
AND I NEVER REALIZED THE DEPTH
OF THE CORRUPTION.
I ALWAYS THOUGHT JOE BIDEN
INTELLECTUALLY WAS CHALLENGED,
BUT A NICE GUY.
I NEVER KNEW THE DEPTH OF HIS
CORRUPTION.
IT IS MASSIVE, SHOCKING AND IF I
PLAYED A ROLE IN GETTING THAT
OUT, I DO A SERVICE TO MY
COUNTRY AND I'M PROUD OF IT.
EVERYTHING I DO IS DEFENSIBLE
AND EVERYTHING I DID WAS LEGAL.
MOST OF WHAT THEY ARE DOING IS
TO COVER UP FOR A CRIME.
AND I WOULD HAPPY TO HAVE BEEN A
CHALLENGE ME BECAUSE EVERY TIME
THEY CHALLENGE ME, THEY GO DOWN
AND WE WIN.
BECAUSE THEY ARE ACTING
IMPROPERLY.
THEY ARE ACTING WITH ABUSE OF
POWER AND THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES CONVERSATION WITH
THAT PRESIDENT, IF YOU CONSIDER
JOE BIDEN AND HIS SON WERE, HOW
CORRUPT HIM IT WAS NECESSARY AND
YOU CANNOT LET THE
VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES ALLOW HIS SON TO
ENRICH HIMSELF TO THE TUNE OF
MILLIONS AND MILLIONS OF DOLLAR
DOLLARS.
>> Laura: WHY ARE YOU THE ONE
TO DO THIS?
WHY IS THIS THE ROLE OF THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT OR THE FBI?
WHY TEST YOU THE PRESIDENT --
THE ATTORNEY OF THE PRESIDENT?
THAT IS A QUESTION LEHMAN, I GET
IT, THAT SHOULD BE INVESTIGATED
BUT WHY IS RUDY RUNNING THE SHOW
ON THAT?
WHY ISN'T IT FBI AND MAIN
JUSTICE?
>> THAT IS A VERY GOOD QUESTION.
BECAUSE THE FBI PERFORMANCE IS
THE ENTIRE INVESTIGATION
INCLUDING UP TO THIS MOMENT IS
FLAWED.
WHY AM I DOING IT, LAURA?
CAN'T YOU FIGURE IT OUT?
I'M A DEFENSE LAWYER.
I'M DEFENDING HIM.
HE'S MY CLIENT.
I DON'T KNOW, ONLY DONALD TRUMP
IS NOT ENTITLED TO DEFENSE IN
AMERICA.
>> Laura: BUT HOW ARE YOU
DEEPENING HIM BY INVESTIGATING
BIDEN?
SPELL IT OUT FOR US.
>> ONE OF THE THINGS THE
PROSECUTOR THAT BIDEN HAD FIRED
AND THEN THE PROSECUTOR THAT
BIDEN HELPED TO PUT IN, ONE OF
THE THINGS THEY DID WAS TO
DISMISS A CASE AGAINST AN
ORGANIZATION THAT WAS COLLECTING
PULSE INFORMATION ABOUT
DONALD TRUMP, ABOUT
PAUL MANAFORT, AND FEEDING IT TO
THE DEMOCRATIC NATIONAL
COMMITTEE.
>> Laura: OKAY, THAT EXPLAINS
IT.
I DON'T THINK PEOPLE UNDERSTOOD
THAT.
>> THAT WAS NOT RUN BY
GEORGE SOROS WHO HIRED THE
CROOKED FBI AGENT WHO IS NOW
WORKING FOR GEORGE SOROS.
LAURA, THIS STINKS.
THIS IS TAMMANY HALL, NEW YORK
POLITICS TO THE TUNE OF
$1 BILLION.
IT IS EXTINCT.
I SPENT MY LIFE AS A PROSECUTOR
WITH DEMOCRATS, CROOKED
REPUBLICANS.
I DON'T CARE WHO IS CROOKED,
THEY SHOULD GO TO JAIL.
THESE PEOPLE ABUSED POWER.
YOU KNOW WHAT, THE CROOKED
PRESS CORPS ENABLES THEM.
THEY DON'T COVER THEM.
THEY ONLY COVER REPUBLICANS.
THERE ARE TWO SYSTEMS OF JUSTICE
IN THE COUNTRY.
THEY GO AFTER REPUBLICANS IF YOU
SAY SOMETHING WRONG.
THEY ALLOW DEMOCRATS TO STEAL
MILLIONS AND THEY DON'T CARE.
THE CLINTONS ENRICH THEMSELVES
ON PUBLIC OFFICE TO THE TENS OF
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS.
THE BIDEN'S GOT $1.5 BILLION
FROM CHINA WHICH HAD TO BE A
DELIBERATE ACT ON THE PART OF
CHINA TO BUY THE VICE
PRESIDENCY.
THAT'S A LOT OF MONEY TO BUY IT.
THEY DIDN'T INVEST IN THE HEDGE
FUND BECAUSE IT MADE MONEY.
IT MADE NO MONEY.
CHINA'S IS NOT STUPID.
THEY DID NOT SPEND MONEY FOR NO
REASON.
THERE IS ONLY ONE REASON TO
SPEND THAT MONEY IT IS TO ABIDE
JOE BIDEN'S OFFICE.
IT DOESN'T BELONG TO HIM BUT THE
PEOPLE OF THE UNITED STATES.
IF A PRESIDENT CANNOT VINDICATE
THAT, IT IS A SAD DAY FOR
AMERICA.
I'M PROUD OF MY PRESIDENT
BECAUSE HE'S TRYING TO CLEAN UP
A SWAMP THAT IS MUCH MORE THAN
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE REALIZE.
IT IS DISGUSTING.
>> Laura: SCHUMER WARNED ABOUT
THE DEEP STATE.
THEY WILL ALWAYS FIND A WAY TO
GET YOU.
>> NOT IF YOU HAVE COURAGE.
>> Laura: PEOPLE, HOLD ON,
RUDY, HOLD ON.
PEOPLE INSIDE THE ADMINISTRATION
AND I'VE SAID THIS FROM JANUARY
JANUARY 6TH, 2017, THEY ARE
LEAKING.
THERE WERE PEOPLE AT THE VERY
BEGINNING LEAKING AND BOLD ALL
THE WAY THROUGH THE DEEP STATE
AND A LOT OF OTHER PEOPLE
PUTTING NETWORKS AS
COMMENTATORS.
IT IS ABSOLUTELY REPRIMAND A
BOWL.
RUDY, THERE IS A THING IN THE
STORY, YOU CLEARED UP A LOT, AND
I DON'T FOLLOW EVERY ITERATION
BECAUSE IT IS COMPLICATED
BECAUSE PEOPLE DON'T FOLLOW IT.
>> IT IS COMPLICATED.
AND THEY ARE TRYING TO COVER IT
IN A COMPLICATED WAY.
>> Laura: IT IS IMPORTANT
PEOPLE UNDERSTAND THIS BECAUSE
WHEN THEY HEAR STUFF, OH, I
HEARD THAT SPAN AND IT'S WRONG.
WHAT IS THE DEAL ABOUT UKRAINIAN
AMBASSADOR TO THE U.S. BECAUSE
PART OF THIS STORY AGAIN BROKE
TONIGHT IS THAT YOU WERE PUTTING
BIG PRESSURE ON HER AS PART OF
THE SCENARIO, U.S. AMBASSADOR OF
THE UKRAINE, EXCUSE ME.
>> I WAS SITTING IN MY OFFICE
NOVEMBER 2018 AND A VERY
PROMINENT INVESTIGATION AND BOTH
CAME TO ME AND TOLD ME, THERE IS
A STORY ABOUT THE UKRAINE AND
WHAT THE DEMOCRATS DID THAT WILL
SHOCK YOU.
AND I DIDN'T BELIEVE IT AT
FIRST.
BIDEN WASN'T INVOLVED.
IT WAS ALL ABOUT COLLUSION,
WHICH BY THE WAY, IS -- AND
PEOPLE WERE PAYING FOR IT.
AND THE AMERICAN AMBASSADOR WAS
DEEPLY INVOLVED.
THE FBI AGENT WHO WAS
INVESTIGATING IT WAS DEEPLY
INVOLVED IN IT.
SHE IS NOW WORKING FOR
GEORGE SOROS, THE FBI AGENT IS
WORKING FOR GEORGE SOROS MAKING
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS.
INVOLVED IN IT BACK THEN.
IN JANUARY 2016, THE OBAMA
WHITE HOUSE TOLD UKRAINIAN
OFFICIALS, GO GET DIRT ON TRUMP
AND PAUL MANAFORT.
NANCY PELOSI DOESN'T CARE ABOUT
THAT.
>> Laura: WHO IN THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION?
THE OBAMA WHITE HOUSE, THAT IS
WHAT WAS TOLD TO YOU?
>> THAT IS WHAT IS REPORTED AND
THEY HELD BY JOHN SOLOMON.
I'VE SEEN SOME OF THE DOCUMENTS.
AND THEN MET JOE BIDEN REMOVES
THE PROSECUTOR AND SAID HE
DIDN'T EVEN KNOW HIS SON WAS
UNDER INVESTIGATION WHICH IS
ABSURD, BUT HE NEVER TALKED TO
HIS SON, FORM BUSINESS?
DO YOU BELIEVE THAT?
DON'T YOU THINK I CAN PROVE HE
DID?
DO YOU THINK I'M STUPID?
DO YOU THINK I'M GIVING ALL MY
EVIDENCE?
>> Laura: RUDY, QUESTION.
>> THEY HAVE WALKED INTO A TRAP.
>> Laura: SO THIS IS A GIFT TO
YOU.
THIS WHOLE THING IS A BIG GIFT
TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE FOR
TRANSPARENCY.
>> YOU ARE DARN RIGHT IT IS A
GIFT.
MAYBE, JUST MAYBE WE WILL
FINALLY INVESTIGATE THE
DEMOCRATS LIKE WE DID A
REPUBLICAN.
MAYBE, JUST MAY BE THE BIG
HILLARY CLINTON FIX.
LIKE THE FBI DID.
TO WRAP HER OUT FOR A CRIME SO
HORRENDOUS AND OBVIOUS ANYBODY
WOULD BE -- IF BIDEN GETS AWAY
WITH $1.5 MILLION THEN WE DON'T
HAVE JUSTICE IN AMERICA.
WE HAVE LOST THE FBI AND WHO
KNOWS WHAT ELSE.
>> Laura: WELL BILL BARR, --
>> INABILITY TO INVESTIGATE THIS
IS ASTOUNDING.
YOU KNOW HOW IT FIRST CAME TO
ME?
A PROMINENT INVESTIGATOR TELLING
ME WHEN YOU'RE THEY WERE TRYING
TO GET THIS TO THE FBI.
YOU ASKED ME WHY DID I DO IT?
BECAUSE THE FBI DIDN'T DO THEIR
JOB.
MAYBE THEY ARE AFRAID THEY WILL
EXPOSE CROOKED AGENTS.
I WILL SHOW YOU THE STATEMENTS
FROM FIVE UKRAINIANS THAT SAY
AND DESPERATELY TRIED TO GET THE
INFORMATION OF THE FBI THAT WE
WERE BLOCKED BY THE AMBASSADOR
WHO EVENTUALLY GOT FIRED.
>> Laura: WE WERE JUST
HEARING, BY THE WAY, HOLD ON,
THAT TRUMP IS GOING TO MEET WITH
UKRAINIAN PRESIDENT AT 2:2:15
TOMORROW.
>> WOULD YOU EMPHASIZE THE FACT
THAT UKRAINIAN PRESIDENT SAID --
>> Laura: FOR SECOND IS WHERE
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE TAKEN US.
UKRAINE SAID IT WAS NOT
PRESSURED BUT THE TRANSCRIPTS
ARE COMING OUT.
>> HE IS THE ONLY ONE THAT
COUNTS AS EXTORTION.
>> Laura: RUDY, WE ARE OUT OF
TIME.